[Music]
I for the last 10 years I've been a
digital product designer and I noticed
that my journaling actually allowed me
to think in a completely different way
so even when I would be designing
different kinds of software applications
from watch interfaces to video game
interfaces it always started out on
paper and over time I realized that the
more I could actually take my thoughts
offline the clearer they would become
and the more I could focus because I
mean you could sit down and start typing
out you can journal in an app but I
noticed I'd be journaling in an AB next
thing I know I'm ordering shoes online
and you have no idea how you got from
one point to the other but when you sit
down with a notebook and as soon as you
engage with the page you are unplugged
so it forces you to really engage with
your thoughts in a way that I feel has
not been accurately replicated in the
digital space so for me the act of
bullet journaling is an act of thinking
it's an act of unplugging and actually
processing the information and in my
community I've found that that's also
provided significant value to people who
get caught up in the rush of everyday
life it's a moment that you can take
back it's a moment where you can really
have the luxury of sitting down and
starting to digest the things that you
otherwise can easily be overwhelmed by I
think one thing that we often kind of
forget is just because something is
convenient does not make it efficient so
a lot of times data entry if you type
for example happens a lot faster but in
that process a lot gets lost because
you're just kind of parroting the source
and I think that it's really important
to actually hear what's being said then
just simply kind of spitting it back out
onto paper so when you're writing a lot
of the time what you want to do is
reduce the amount of information that
you're capturing only down to what truly
matters
so you're distilling information in real
time and in order to do that you have to
think about what truly matters and I
feel like writing by hand allows us to
think significantly more about the
information that
we are writing down I mean the actual
act of writing activates very many
different parts of our brain
simultaneously that from the science
that I have seen doesn't happen when
you're typing so for example students
that were separated into two separate
groups one was allowed to take notes via
handwriting and the other via typing and
the group that wrote by hand retained
the information significantly longer and
significantly more accurately so I think
that when you concentrate and you focus
on writing you are engaging with content
significantly more you have to you're
the weight of the pen the the the ideas
the concepts that you're trying to
distill down to what matters how your
handwriting looks how quickly you're
writing and all those things immediately
focus your attention more so than I
would say but typing would so decision
fatigue is when you find yourself
literally exhausted by the amount of
decisions that you have to make because
we're constantly inundated by so many
different things from so many different
channels all that information requires
our attention and a lot of that
information actually requires us to act
and acting on information is essentially
making a decision so do you want to go
watch this movie do you want to go on
this trip do you want to respond to this
email do you do you do you do you have
to constantly keep asking yourself and
you're making a decisions and over time
the more you allow yourself to be
inundated by without taking a step back
the more exhausted you get it might not
be physically right you can make
decisions all day long and you can still
run a marathon but our mind also has a
limited amount of energy your ability to
make decisions becomes worse it can
really quickly degrade when you're
constantly making decisions and again
for me journaling is a big part of that
because a lot of these decisions don't
add value to our life we're thinking
about things just because they're there
not because they actually mean something
to us and a lot of the time I think we
forget that just because something could
be done doesn't mean that it needs to be
done
and it certainly shouldn't be taking up
our time and our energy and our focus we
live in a we live in an age of unlimited
possibility and possibilities all
require us to make a decision and I
think it's really important to realize
that we are very limited our attention
is limited our time is very limited and
if we start to structure our days around
that concept then we can start to we can
start to protect the time that we do
have and start trying to make decisions
based on things that do matter to us a
thing before we make the decision we
have to make the decision to be very
careful about what we let into our lives
and if we don't we suffer from decision
fatigue
[Music]